[Musique]
jacky copains pourquoi avoir appelé ce
lieu de rencontre le casino nous l'avons
appelé le casino parce que c'est le lieu
où nous réunissons d'habitude nous
sommes un petit groupe de jeunes ici qui
aimeraient chanter oui alors nous nous
réunissons d'abord dans les bistrots et
ensuite quand les bistrots sont fermés
nous venons ici et comme c'est un petit
club si vous voulez nous sommes entre
nous et ne faut pas la cravate il on est
comme ça vient casser la croûte alors
nous l'avons appelé le casino part
peut-être pas pour humilier les gens de
bonne compagnie d'hommes enfin à
l'avandia par casino alors nous avons
fait notre casino et vous chanter des
chansons à la factory une chanson une
chantant des chansons surtout
folkloriques ou en français ou en bateau
un peu importe où vous en avez réuni
beaucoup
actuellement nous en avons copié réunis
150 environ et nous comptons bien
continuer est arrivé aux 250 et pensées
et les attentes en faisant chanter en
faisant chanter les plus âgés ceux qui
le savent ce qu'ils ont entendu c'est
que vous devez pas que ce patrimoine
stern ne voulons pas qu'ils se perdent
et se consacre aux avons copié et c'est
pour ça que nous nous réunissons des
temps en temps pour les remettre dans le
vent alors pour nous faire plaisir à ce
que voudriez nous chanter maintenant une
chanson qui vous semblent
particulièrement typique de la rance si
vous voulez nous avons chanté par
exemple pastore jeunes qui est la
chanson d'un berger qui est en montagne
et qui rencontrent bien entendu une
bergère l'histoire se passe dans des
contrats d'une valeur en fin au bord de
l'eau un peu puis tous les deux
s'appelle l'autre et chanter une chanson
avec chacun leur à sa trompette sur la
chanson se trompent est l'autre salir et
tous les deux sont à l'unisson ils sont
tranquilles dans son coin personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
bertha
et
s'évader
jonah hill aucun soleil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il aimait en vélo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le garçonnet
[Musique]
belge
milow
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au
[Musique]
ddt
et c'est non
enyeama stephano
[Musique]
la condamnation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est autorisée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'accord d'alger
signé des
chronos
il omet autorisée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]